a crisis that has been raging for months
millions of acres of land destroyed as
hundreds of fires burn around the
country bush fires are a normal part of
the Australian summer but not like this
the ferocity of this year's is prompting
authorities to take extreme measures in
Australia's most populous state New
South Wales will be in a state of
emergency from today for the next seven
days as you are aware this is the second
state of emergency we've declared since
the fires commenced in July whilst today
is going to be a very bad day a
dangerous day here in New South Wales
the forecast is that Saturday will be
even worse so we're talking about some
very serious and dangerous conditions
over the coming days the state of
emergency means the fire service will
have authority to shut down utilities
like water and electricity close roads
demolish buildings and evacuate
residents Sydney's famous harbour views
have been completely transformed by the
disaster and frustrations are growing
the combination of the bushfire crisis
droughts heat waves all sparking
criticism of the government's climate
policies a group of protesters most of
them high school students gathered
outside the Prime Minister's house
braving the smoky air and uncomfortable
heat to stage a sit-in I'm just really
sick of what's been happening we're just
being ignored by the government for
weeks and weeks there's almost a
festival atmosphere at this sit-in just
outside the Prime Minister's residence
there's music and games but the
protesters here say that they're serious
about their message that the government
isn't doing enough to stop what they're
calling a climate emergency there's bush
fires across the country there are heat
waves across the country and they're not
doing anything about it we've seen a 25%
increase in respiratory presentations to
hospitals across Sydney because of this
bushfire crisis near pollution that's
resulting from that we're seeing
deepening health inequalities because of
government inaction on climate change
and it's negligent and it's actually
killing people
Prime Minister Morrison wasn't home to
hear their message he's on holiday and
is due to return later this week to face
the heat authorities warned the volatile
situation will grow even more dangerous
in the coming days with strong winds and
soaring temperatures forecast
Jessica Washington al Jazeera Sydney